Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two. David, P.. Here's
kind of a funny tongue in cheek voicemail. But
it's also very accurate. Take a listen to this.
David, I think it's about time that we start
calling these right wing nuts what they really
are communist sympathizers right now. It's sort of
tongue in cheek, but at the same time, I mean, you
know, Russia is not at this point what we would
call a communist country. But by most definitions,
although there are people who would still say
it's guiding principles are still those same
communist principles of the USSR. But the point
is a good one, which is the right spent decades
at this point. Building, building, building the
story that the American left just kind of like
basic Democrats, are socialists, Marxists and
or communists. But it is actually the right that
through Donald Trump, being enamored with
these right wing, authoritarian, dictatorial
authoritarians has ended up being the bigger
supporters of those with communist leanings for
lack of a better term. Good luck explaining the
double standard to them. We've got a great bonus
show for you today. The Senate has approved a bill
to make daylight saving time permanent. Do we like
this? And will it actually happen? We'll discuss.
Idaho is now copying the Texas anti-abortion law,
and this is exactly what we expected, and
they're doing it. We will talk about that.
And yes, Jenny Thomas, the wife of Supreme Court
Justice Clarence Thomas, was at the January 6th
rally that preceded the Jan. six Trump
riots. We will talk about what we know,
and we will talk about how this may end
up connecting to the current January 6th
Committee investigation of those Trump riots. All
of those stories and more on today's bonus show.
Speaker 4: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money and everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Very dangerous bonus show.
If you believe Alex Jones, I consider
it an absolute delight. Sign up at Join
Packman dot com. You'll get instant access.
Unidentified: And I will speak to that.